[Music]
sometimes even the best team is to slip
up they lose two three even four players
early and things look mean that's when
the best of the best step up to the
plate and put their teams on their backs
those of the players were celebrating
this week the comeback kings of siege
but before we get into it if you want a
cool shirt like I'm wearing or another
less Korey sports shirt you can check
out the score eSports and merch store
you'll find a link in the comments below
so let's get into it
from crazy shotgun plays to insane 1v5
comebacks let's count down the top ten
clutches in rainbow six siege kicking
off our list is team vitality breed a
who find himself in a 1v4 clutch
situation against Team Liquid most of
liquids players were low on health as
they took B site and free day was ready
to clean them up with his trusty shotgun
up close with the shotgun
there's no diffuser it's not been said
just yet they put it on the other side
put it there with one canister right
into sexy cake right in the face oh my
god what is that what a defensive window
oh just clutching it up so hard coming
in at number nine is Leon get to why
does yokai drone brilliantly tucked away
by the lockers at the half wall and
armory this pesky yokai was so well
placed that not even the opposing IQ
could take it out and because the drone
survived the whole round millennium are
left without the diffuser planted making
for an easy clutch keep in mind that
when Leon gets to live there is still a
yokai very much in play but live and
we'll see it black he's still in a
perfect denial position he'll whip out
the shotgun to make it happen and it
looks like he's gonna not make me
successful aces will finish him off
the yokai drone though from Leon will
deny the plant in the final seconds oh
so much damage done from that one yokai
and they knew was there for almost the
entire round sometimes killing the
opposing team is not enough to secure
the win after all there is an objective
to be played in Rainbow six siege and
our number eight spot calls back to the
time that execration had to race back to
the
user after going out of his way to
secure the final kill he sees the spray
and the tracers give away the position
but the vault from capital might be the
perfect play X is on the defuser but he
knows he can't stick it because of the
repel but the vault Oh will he have time
is the real question only time will tell
we can't possibly know Wow
X what a clutch number 7 on our list is
an oldie but a goodie and it's a classic
showcasing of this legendary squads
teamwork yes it's that time that Penghu
managed to win an intense 1 v 2 against
playing ducks and despite Penghu being
the last one standing for his squad
fabian was walking him through the
situation over comms showing us at a
good clutch doesn't have to be done
alone to a two-on-two with 25 seconds to
go Penghu still here another shield on
the gun snuke is gonna rush on out of
their lackeys gonna pick up one they
know the last ones in connector 15
seconds it's a pulse it's a full second
the defuser is been recovered ten people
in expose it drop down drop down they're
bound up down five seconds remaining
coming in at number six is a time that
Eclipse clutched a W against three
members of obey alliance with the
defuser planted Eclipse managed to bring
it down to a 1v1 and in a short
firefight both players found with no one
left to destroy the defuser you've got
his teammate Eclipse watching if there's
a push through security skies will take
out slash though it look at this eclipse
with one to four eclipses all this is
winnable they will need to defuse and
the time running out but it could but
rogue will take it a trade to finish
things off how does this happen
so so unbelievable I don't think we have
ever seen that before
for most operators in the seed the
pistol is a last resort and when you run
into bullets for your primary gun and
makes clutching the round that much
harder but coming in at number 5 is
pieces who whipped out his pistol in the
nick of time to drop faze clan to the
floor pieces from the hallway will get
Astro Gohan a second one for himself but
Asus shuts him down zero on the clock
but the defuser has been planted the
pistol formation is what is happening
our goal is to get stall laws will
clutch it out thanks to the bandit bite
himself and two in a row for the
Europeans all about a sneeze again two
rounds in a row he's the man on the
building at the moment and he's stepping
up so hard for his team it should come
as no surprise that the number four play
marks Brunei's second appearance on our
list against no tango brie de found
himself taking on three attackers that
we're looking to plant the defuser sure
thermite was in a safe spot behind the
mattress with two teammates covering him
but that didn't stop free day from doing
what he does best goes for another one
onto the windows for balcony it's the
second follow-up shot on 2jj getting the
stature but the fuse is being planted
right now near islands and then what is
happening by Tony take it 7 SEC
200 in the series are you kidding me
what have we just witnessed we've seen
fights Holly take the Ernie and then the
quick fork a common oil from noir Arango
percenter won't be free and bread who's
been new to clutch up so much more vital
ticks sometimes patience is the key to
winning a clutch and spark perfectly
demonstrates this in our number 3 play
as he shows off excellent trigger
discipline to take out three ends
players then with vitality as diffuser
planted and says will key was left in an
impossible 1v1 nez spark gets pushed on
he is very wisely not getting initials
records at Red Bull kill will key now
and a 1vs1
he might have the yokai still but it's a
post plant situation flame
the long game expecting to push from
Wilkie in here it comes Wilkie checks
the wrong angle
and he goes back in for the defuser
there's no time spark clutches it out in
a one versus four in our runner-up spot
is fanatics aces who lives up to his
name with this insane sequence of kills
after taking out one of nips players
aces was faced with a one before/after
plan the maestro was quick to equalize a
server but it was his final kill the
left his teammates in disbelief Jesus
gets one psycho is aware that there's
one playing on stairs I mean it will
take out Neal fighter plant going down
somewhat successfully but no aces season
aces coming in can he get it to big
kills from aces he sees the double up
third aces oh my goodness it'll one
thing down get off the plan the maestro
will shoot away at the wall oh my god oh
my word ace is a huge clutch and he'll
get the defuser fanatic mind God what
around one around ace is living up to
his name
what a performance winning a one before
is great and all but you know what's
even better winning a 1v5 when the
entire round falls on your shoulders
there's only one thing to do kill them
all
which is exactly what Ness did at our
number one spot we could talk more about
this play but it's one you really have
to see to believe
my budget is a triple Q through cod
lemansky if you're lucky you get stuck
with this your grandfather he would see
you selected upon second you pick so
many - goose egg yolk like a shoe clutch
keep orgy ecology awful fancy character
new species of a provocative itza so
what do you think did we catch a palace
if you think we missed anything be sure
to let us know in the comments below and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe
Collin will be coming back in the clutch
for you next week thanks for watching if
you want more great content just like
this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
you